Time to find my new voice.
Stephen.
It's me, surely it has to be me.
Listen to my voice.
It's deep.
It's sexy.
It's got a tinge of physics.
Hi, I'm Rebel Wilson and I'm reading for the role of Stephen Hawking.
He's a really smart guy, so I think we'd be a perfect match, really.
I am the obvious choice.
I'm intelligent.
Kind of.
And I'm young and cool.
Hello Stephen, it's Stephen here.
Listen, I think my voice would endow your presence with an enormous authority.
You'll also be able to use many cogently...
My earpiece is gone.
You'd be able to use lots of long words and stuff.
Are you kidding me?
A number of people decided to do what they do best.
My job is to find stars.
Your job is to look at them, count them, whatever it is you do.
Did Liam Neeson do the whole phone call, like...
I don't know who you are.
I don't know what you want.
Did he?
It has to be a yes from you.
No.
Not a chance.